The Game Awards just happened and while
there were plenty of winners and moving
speeches on stage there was also a good
chunk of news I'm Tony and this game
spot news update will break down the
best of it first up Telltale Games the
rumors said the studio would be taking
on guardians of the galaxy next and they
were right it's coming in 2017 also of
note Telltale's walking dead season 3
titled a new frontier we'll have a
two-part premiere speaking of premieres
we also saw a trailer for dauntless a
new co-op RPG coming to pcs in 2017
developer Phoenix labs was founded by X
Bioware and Blizzard people so you know
they know their RPGs and speaking of
RPGs we also got some hot new Mass
Effect Andromeda gameplay the footage
showed off the game's combat and an
array of new powers including one that
lets riders zip around the battlefield
in a flash of blue energy let's stay in
space a bit longer and talk about pray
the new trailer showed off a bunch of
the game's creepy enemies and
protagonist Morgan use range of powers
and weapons pray looks to have some
serious atmosphere pun not intended as
for other trailers today Okajima was on
stage to give us another quick look at
death stranding this second trailer
featured some more well-known film
industry folks with Guillermo del Toro
clutching a weird baby at a bottle and
Mads Mikkelsen commanding soldiers with
creepy tentacles and finally we got a
look at the shovel Knight prequel
spectre of torment so you can expect
plenty of new bosses and levels when
that drops in 2017 a can and a game
awards story without mentioning at least
one winner so congratulations to the
overwatch team for winning best game
overall but which trailer was your
favorite let me know in the comments or
on twitter at chaingun Pope and for all
the biggest video game news you're
already in the right place
[Music]